-After more classified documents
were found
at the homes of President Biden
and former
Vice President Mike Pence,
Donald Trump's supporters
in the GOP
and on Fox News claimed Trump
had been vindicated,
while also spreading
wild conspiracy theories
about the news.
But, if anything,
the cases of Biden and Pence
make Trump's potentially
criminal behavior
look a lot worse.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Trump supporters in the GOP
and on Fox News
have been twisting themselves
in knots
over the revelations
about classified documents found
at the homes of Trump,
Biden, and Pence.
For example,
when the news first broke
that the FBI had searched
Mar-a-Lago last year
and discovered
top secret documents
that Trump had lied about having
and refused to give back,
you might recall
that many Republicans
dismissed it as a nonscandal.
They threw out every excuse
they could think of --
it was a storage issue,
the FBI was just fishing,
they planted evidence,
or even that Trump
was just a little sloppy
because he didn't have time
to pack.
-This is really, at its core,
a storage argument.
I don't think a fight
over storage of documents
is worthy of what they've done.
-This was a fishing expedition.
It was an old-fashioned,
fake fishing expedition.
I actually think it had little
to nothing
to do with classified documents.
-No one trusts the FBI
or the DOJ anymore.
I don't trust them any further
than I can throw
that entire building.
If they told me
that they found something,
I wouldn't know that they
actually found it there
or if they just said
they found it there.
-Who is to say,
in this kind of case,
that some of the documents
supposedly seized
were not planted there,
to begin with?
-Do I know that the boxes
of material
they took from Mar-a-Lago,
that they won't put things
in those boxes to entrap him?
How do we know that they're
going to be honest with us
about what's actually
in the boxes?
-When the president moves
out of the White House,
you have effectively, you know,
six hours to move
out of the White House.
It's effectively
inauguration time
where one president
gets moved out
and one president gets moved in.
-No, you don't have six hours!
You have two months!
[ Laughter ]
But, unfortunately, your dad
spent those two months bitching
and moaning
and planning a coup
to stay in power.
And then,
when it didn't work out
and the moving van showed up,
he just screamed --
[ As Trump ] Oh, [bleep],
grab everything and run!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Your dad was the first president
to leave office
like a looter at Best Buy
during a blackout.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You guys are acting
like the inauguration
is a surprise party
where they keep the date secret
until the last minute.
[ Laughter ]
I don't remember
Joe Biden walking
into the Capitol,
flicking the lights on,
and seeing thousands
of people assembled.
[ As Biden ]
Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
What the hell is this?!
Although, it is ve...ry hard
to surprise Joe Biden.
He is always on alert.
That's why he tiptoes
into every room,
like someone about to pop out
[ Laughter and applause ]
from behind a couch
and he freezes every time
he hears a noise.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
You here, Aunt Cathy?
[ Laughter ]
I can hear you breathing.
Then there was also
the ridiculous excuse
that Trump is just
a nostalgic guy
who loves to save little
mementos and keepsakes.
-My father-in-law,
as anybody knows,
who's been around him a lot,
loves to save things,
like newspaper clippings,
magazine clippings, photographs.
-My father always
kept clippings.
You know, press clippings.
He would have, you know,
newspaper articles,
pictures, notes from us.
-[ As Eric ]
He saves every note
I've ever given him.
In fact, he has a special
storage bin where he puts them.
He showed it to me.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, I think I know
where Trump puts notes
from his weird adult sons.
I'm not going to say where,
but it would explain why
he's always talking about this.
-People are flushing toilets
[ Laughter and applause ]
10 times, 15 times,
as opposed to once.
-[ As Trump ]
You got to flush 15 times,
otherwise, you'll never get rid
of that big stack
of Father Day cards.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, those were all the excuses
Trump supporters offered
when Trump got caught
with hundreds
of classified documents
that he lied about
and refused, for over a year,
to turn over,
despite multiple requests
and a subpoena.
But then, when Biden found
and voluntarily turned over
a much smaller cache
of documents
from his time as a senator
and vice president,
Republicans suddenly changed
their tune
and claimed it was
a national security emergency
because, unlike Trump,
Biden supposedly did not have
the power to declassify
documents.
-The president has the authority
to declassify a document.
Now, the question is whether
or not the president
actually declassified
the documents.
The vice president does not have
the authority to declassify.
-President Trump, as president,
has the right
to declassify documents,
so, the media should
cover the fact
that the FBI has been weaponized
against President Trump
and, clearly, has covered up
for sitting president Joe Biden.
-Let's be very clear -- like we
said, from the beginning,
a former vice president,
or anybody else,
has no ability to remove
classified documents.
Former presidents are different.
-Joe Biden conceivably
stole those documents.
What people need
to understand is
the president
of the United States
is the only one that can
declassify documents,
not the vice president.
-Right.
-For Joe Biden
to steal documents
and have possession of them,
this is a serious investigation.
-[ As Greene ]
This is very serious
and that's why I'm calling
on QAnon
[ Laughter and applause ]
and the Jewish space laser
to step in and investigate
and it should be easy
to track everyone's movements
using the microchip Bill Gates
planted in the COVID vaccine.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Which I appreciate he did, now.
[ Cheering ]
First of all,
that's flat-out wrong.
Biden did have the power
to declassify the documents
as vice president.
That doesn't mean he should've
had them in his home.
He shouldn't have.
Although, again,
as we stated before,
it's not exactly surprising
to me
that Joe Biden didn't take
document security seriously
during his time
as Obama's vice president.
I mean, look at him.
That is...
[ Laughter ]
...definitely the face of a dude
who might take documents
and who definitely has a bunch
of towels at home
with hotel names on them.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, Trump supporters had
to pivot
when the documents were found
in Biden's home.
Then they got thrown
for yet another loop
when classified documents
were also found
at the home of former
Vice President Mike Pence.
Some Republicans responded
to the news
by just throwing their hands up
and saying, "Screw it."
Like Lindsey Graham, who,
instead of making
a political point,
decided to just make a joke.
-You got Trump, you got Pence,
you got Biden.
The only thing I think
you'll find at my house is
a bunch of Chick-fil-A bags
on the floor.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. But in fairness,
there's a good chance
those were stolen from the
Trump White House, too.
[ Laughter ]
It would not surprise me
if Trump wrote "Classified"
on every fast food box
that came through there.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Other Trump supporters, however,
tried to thread the needle
by claiming Trump and Pence
were innocent,
but Biden was, somehow, guilty,
like Ted Cruz, who called
the FBI search of Mar-a-Lago
a fishing expedition.
Cruz demanded more FBI searches
of Biden and his family,
while also dismissing
the Pence news as no big deal.
-I believe the FBI needs
to search the residences
of Hunter Biden
and any business offices
to determine if there are
classified materials there.
-Just as an addendum to this,
the news came out today --
I'm sure you saw it --
that former
Vice President Mike Pence,
a friend of both of ours,
he's found
some classified documents,
I think, at his home in Indiana,
not in his office.
What do you make of that?
-Oh, look, the Mike Pence story,
it's still early.
You know, Mike Pence --
and, as you noted,
he is a good friend,
he's a good man --
he's explained
where these came from.
That was a mistake,
but there's no reason
to think it was anything
but inadvertent.
-Within a matter of seconds,
he went from saying
the FBI should search
the president's son,
who has no connection
to any of this,
to brushing off the Pence news
as inadvertent.
Why aren't you calling
on the FBI to search
Mike Pence's other properties,
like his office
or that happy place in his head
he goes to
when he's in a meeting
with Donald Trump?
[ Laughter ]
Other Fox hosts
tried other excuses,
like claiming Pence's mistake
was understandable
because he didn't have much time
to leave the White House.
-Biden says he was in a rush
to pack up his stuff
after his vice presidency.
Wait a second.
I think Mike Pence was
in a little bit more of a rush.
[ Laughing ]
Remember that transition?
And Biden knew he was leaving
the White House.
It had been eight years.
You're not allowed
to stay any longer.
Pence was looking
around, saying, "Wait,
is Trump going
to pull this off?"
-Wait, you think Mike Pence,
known for, among other things,
the January 6th rioters chanting
[ Laughing ] "Hang Mike Pence,"
[ Laughter ]
didn't pack because he
was waiting to see
if the coup would succeed?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Pence ] If I spend all day
packing boxes
and writing on them
with a Sharpie
and then I get killed,
I'm going to feel so stupid.
[ Laughter ]
And we know Pence wasn't
in a rush to pack
because we've seen what he looks
like when he's in a rush.
He claps when he runs.
[ Laughter ]
If Pence had been rushing
to pack up his office
on the last day, you would've
heard this sound coming
from the White House.
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Clapping rhythmically ]
[ Applause ]
[ As Trump ]
Mike, Mike, are you clapping?
[ Laughter ]
I just -- I want to --
And then,
after they made excuses,
they moved on
to baseless speculation.
For example, Fox host
Laura Ingraham wanted to know
why the FBI hadn't searched
President Obama's home
and office yet.
-On the issue of Obama,
it is curious
why the DOJ hasn't
requested access
to his many offices
across the country,
given the fact that a majority
of Biden's documents came
from his administration.
-I have no idea whether
any classified documents
will show up at his house,
but if there's one person
I'm willing to bet
did things the right way,
it was Obama.
Plus, let's not forget,
he left office
and his life immediately
got way better.
[ Laughter ]
He's not moping
around a country club,
stealing the mic at weddings
to bitch about witch hunts.
[ Laughter ]
He's hanging with celebrities,
kite surfing,
and having the top button
from all his shirts removed.
[ Laughter and applause ]
When he left --
When he left the White House,
they probably said,
"Do you want any of these
documents?" And he said --
[ As Obama ]
Uh...
[bleep] it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You can keep it.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, we tape this show
way before it's on TV,
so, if they find arguments
at Obama's house
[ Laughter ]
between now and airtime,
they were planted
by James Corden
to make me look bad.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
The only other politician
who I can possibly imagine
would have no interest
in taking classified documents
would be Bernie Sanders.
[ As Sanders ]
I don't want your documents.
[ Laughter ]
For too long,
the top 1% of politicians
has had 99% of the documents.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We need to redistribute
the documents.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Everyone can have a fair share
of the documents.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Other Trump allies
reached for distractions,
like Sean Hannity,
who brushed off the Pence news
and turned his attention
to someone else --
and you will never guess who.
-I think Mike Pence was watching
everything with Biden,
top secret documents,
et cetera, et cetera.
He initiated
his own investigation,
just to double-check.
He immediately called the FBI,
when they found a couple
of documents, Matt Gaetz,
and handed them over
and worked with the officials.
But that's not the issue, to me.
The issue is how was
Hillary Clinton treated?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God, dude, let it go.
She already had her
presidential campaign destroyed
by a never-ending saga
over classified emails
and, now, she's got to sit
around and watch
as basically every other living
president or vice president
opens up a [bleep] cereal box
labeled at home...
[ Laughter ]
Just get a new thing.
Find literally anything else
to obsess over.
Go back to whining about how
M&M's are too woke now
or something.
Although, if you ask me,
Mars missed a huge opportunity.
They shouldn't have canceled
the candy mascots.
They should've just jumped
on the news and introduced
a new gray M&M
who steals classified documents.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Probably the craziest reaction
to the Pence news has come
from Fox host Tucker Carlson,
who concocted
an elaborate fantasy
where the DOJ asked Pence
to look for the documents,
assuming he had none,
in order to make Trump
look bad by comparison,
so that they could then
prosecute Trump.
-It wasn't so long ago
that Pence was on television,
saying he was sure he had
no classified documents
in his possession.
He said that a few times.
Then, just days ago, Mike Pence
sent his personal attorney
to search his family's home
in Carmel, Indiana,
for classified documents.
Now, if Mike Pence didn't think
he had classified documents,
why would he send his lawyer
to go look
for classified documents?
We can't say for certain,
but it's entirely possible --
in fact, it's likely --
that Mike Pence was asked
to do this
by federal prosecutors
who are trying to build a case
against his old boss
Donald Trump.
Now, the point would be to show
that not every federal official
walks off of state secrets.
Donald Trump was uniquely evil
in that regard,
as in so many others.
"See?
Mike Pence didn't do it."
So, if that was the plan --
and we suspect that it was --
it backfired spectacularly.
-[ As Carlson ]
If that was the plan,
what else are they planning?
It's possible --
in fact, it's likely --
they were planning
on asking Mike Pence
to go undercover
as Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
And, if that was the plan,
how would they do it?
Would they have arrested
Donald Trump,
so they could perform
an experimental surgery,
wherein they remove
Donald Trump's face
and swap it with Mike Pence,
just like they did
to John Travolta
and Nicolas Cage?
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, if that was the plan,
then what else
were they planning?
Would the real Donald Trump,
now wearing Mike Pence's face,
have escaped, forced to live
his life as Mike Pence?
And would the real Mike Pence,
now disguised as Donald Trump,
have to chase him down
and prove his true identity?
[ Laughter ]
And, if that was the plan --
and we suspect it was...
[ Laughter ]
...it backfired spectacularly
because they forgot one thing --
Mike Pence can catch
Donald Trump
because Mike Pence
runs like this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
In reality, the Biden and Pence
revelations showed
this is a lot more commonplace
than most of us realized
and that, if Trump had just
given the documents back,
when asked,
there wouldn't
have been a problem.
Instead, he lied and obstructed
for over a year.
That's what makes
this case different.
That, and the fact
that he probably had
top secret documents stuffed
inside...
-Chick-fil-A bags on the floor.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]